real housewives of beverly hills star
derek kemsley's husband speaks out after
the couple's home was reportedly robbed
and dorit was held at gunpoint the 54
year old reality star shared this family
photo on instagram friday morning
alongside a lengthy caption thanking
friends and fans for their kind words
and support quote dorit and myself have
been overwhelmed by the show of love we
can't respond to every message so i
wanted to tell you all that we are doing
okay i'm home and we are all together
and we'll get through this on wednesday
night darite was reportedly held at
gunpoint and robbed at their home in the
los angeles suburb of encino while her
two children seven-year-old jagger and
five-year-old phoenix were in the house
according to the daily mail darit and
her kids were the only people in the
house at the time pk was in london as
for how their little ones are doing
following the incident pk explains that
they're doing great and adds that
they're quote totally unaware and life
is going to return to normal hopefully
very soon according to reports the
intruders broke into their home smashing
through the children's classroom door
the damage you can see here this is my
clothes closet clothes and jewelry
the perpetrators then reportedly
ransacked the residents for about 20
minutes stealing dorit's jewelry and
handbags lapd's public information
office tells et there are three male
suspects in the case the invasion
occurred on the same night that part 3
of the season 11 reunion for the real
housewives of beverly hills aired where
dorite opened up about her pricey closet
dory when you come out with these
outfits do you buy every single thing
every single piece i'm i'm really
particular i want to wear what i want to
wear and it's just easier i just think
i'll buy it and you pay retail for
everything yes i would have thought at
this point that you would be getting
discounts from places or that people
would be lending you stuff to see it on
the show really certain designers would
but you know i i want to wear what i
want to wear i dress for myself what i
like but this isn't the first time the
couple's home has been robbed i had a
really really few days we had something
happen that sort of tipped my world
upside down we were away and
we discovered that we had been robbed
all of my handbags all of my jewelry
every single thing
they got everything during the season
nine premiere of the hit bravo series
dorit opened up about being burglarized
while they were out of town i couldn't
cope i said to my husband i need to go
somewhere and collect myself what did
you do i went to utah i climbed a
mountain it was this mental
breakthrough i had where it was like
this strength started to come back the
switch had been flipped and gas went
back into the tank i got these two
little ones and all i kept thinking was
shortly after that incident the couple
moved into their current home so this is
our great room we have indoor outdoor
living which is really nice here in
california because most days you can
have the doors open e.t can confirm real
housewives is currently filming season
12. no word yet if dorite will be
returning for the upcoming season or if
cameras will be following the burglary
but the fourth and final installment of
the season 11 reunion is set to air on
bravo next wednesday